Bruce Campbell I was making his way in
Siegen what's going on man I happened to
be in the neighborhood
yes you're always welcome here welcome
key question there we go
well there we go look at you you look
fantastic well I'm your quitter mention
the show mansion every pocket poof is
that what it is a pocket no that's not a
pocket square when did you when did you
get interested in in the way you dress I
was just out I was interested wait way
back when and then I had kids and then
it went out the window for 15 years and
now it's back why the Quattro endo ah
because kids I wore fanny packs and you
know socks and sandals in those days it
was hot it was a hot any fanny pack yes
nothing what I travel a little bit
really cause the worst I love a good
fanny pack
they are stylistically horrifying but
but functionally astute what's better
than get on a plane everybody's empty
and [ __ ] and you throw your fanny pack
on and you like done yeah easy
it's amazing what it expands to also I
mean the crap that you can put in there
yeah absolutely my license my ID I'm
just gonna sit here ruined his interview
by listing [ __ ] I put my fanny pack
outer zippers - they were more
sophisticated than people rely lucky
fella and I say that with no irony I
genuinely enjoyed your Harry Potter
maybe that's my problem I've been
exposed to the right fanny packs I don't
think there is a right I mean either
there's a practical fanny pack those
days are over so now yeah you do look
very good well in the old days we there
was a there was a church in a rich
suburb of Detroit that gave away they
you could give you can give your clothes
there and they give them away did they'd
sell it for charity for the church oh it
was where all the rich people took their
clothes and this was great stuff so you
can get a wool a wool suit that was
lined in silk for 20 bucks Jesus you get
it tailored for 20 bucks 45 bucks man
you're looking sharpened in the Motor
City and that's how we raised our money
for evil dead the first evil that we we
all wore these secondhand suits and but
Montgomery Montgomery Ward briefcases
and we looked like we were business how
old are you at that point
21
okay all right so you're not in high
school no no just after though you know
not too far after you guys knew you
wanted to finance this movie you had a
script and you just had zero money we
had no idea how to get the money though
it's one thing Sam had an idea he had a
script we met a guy Rob Tapert who
seemed to think he knew how to get money
the good news is he was a young renegade
so his family had a family lawyer
because he was always in trouble so we
went to his lawyers said how do we raise
money he goes you got to create a thing
like an entity right to then approach
businessmen and you speak their language
and you show them that you're not full
of crap
and so that's what we did and then we
showed them a little super 8 movie we
used to do a lot of super 8 movies in
high school we did a super 8 short
version of evil debt and we showed that
to investors and then took their money
it was a long grueling process it really
was it was it took 3 3 plus years to
make the original movie to be the
horrifying part of the old ed it was all
very scary was that the the angle
following the new that that was the most
genius thing in it and the tree branch
evil eye evil entity yeah that was
frightening you shoot that in the demo
reel uh yeah we did shoot some of that
exactly so what it was good for us to to
sort of get our horror chops we had only
made silly three three stooges comedies
before that horror was new to us right
this wasn't something I grew up on I
didn't read any of that crap so how did
you how did you and Sam know how to
shoot that stuff like was it just like
trial and error like let's what if we do
this with the camera a lot of it is Sam
he he's got a real crazy
he's a it was a magician that's how I I
first hung out with him I was his
assistant hung low and we would wear lab
coats and we would appear for bar
mitzvahs and things like that and he
would hit me and he saw the audience
liked it when he hit me so he associated
that get that associated my pain with
entertainment right and he never stopped
was he a good magician he was a good
magician because every day at 4 o'clock
he turned into a bar ah no oh
keep it about no Sam was he looked very
sleight of hand and what are movies the
ultimate sleight of hand the angles that
you use what you show the editing he
he's the only director I know who read
the American cinematographers manual
which is the most boring make you want
to hang yourself a book it's all the
technical side of cameras and shutters
and apertures and F stops T stops forget
it yeah but he's like I have to know
this I have this camera in my hand what
can it do what can I make it do right
and it's impressive what he made it do
so that is impressive because like I
feel like so many especially young
directors student directors whatever
instead of looking at a camera going
what can I make it do are just looking
at other movies and being like ah just
do that no no question about it say and
we and the original Evil Dead we had
days where we filmed for 12 hours and
got one shot Jesus Sam would be fired
he will mired in three days he would um
you know the TV world by lunch you've
killed the bad guy Little Billy got as
medicine back and you know you've kissed
your co-star it happened so fast but Sam
shot is if his shot is I want to be
tracking with ash from London window to
the other above him and even be above
the rafters of the cabin how do we get
that Wow and we're like yeah how do we
get that so we would spend the whole day
figuring out how to get that shot so
then when you get into doing other
movies like after this thing it's a
success in about Vollmer and and you
have a mainstream career and everything
yeah do you go back to Sam and be like
you're not supposed to do it that way
like you we can go way quicker than it
was only Sam still go slow you got yo it
not much has changed as teachers as a
you know there's a now he has resources
though it's even more horrifying
Cassandra go no no here's what I want to
do with the camera now and all of his
Holly all the effects Wizards in
Hollywood they're not going to say no
they love these crazy visual challenges
so it's impressive to watch but boy as a
director of those movies you've got to
have and it you have it you have to have
an attention span I mean the detail this
crap have shooting all these effects the
less
years and you know shooting ash vs. Evil
Dead the news show there's nothing as an
easy shot there's not an easy shot in
the whole show right
you're either green screen or some fake
driving shot where you're projecting
images on the car while you have a
background plates playing that have to
be shot beforehand you know none of it
none of it's two guys sitting and
talking you like oh do you like using
green screen or you like y'all we're
shooting green green screen it's just a
modern day tool and he used to be blue
screen now everything's green screen
before that is called chroma key before
that they had frontscreen projection so
it's going to change a lot pretty soon
that go we don't even need green screen
just we'll just do it which is added and
do it yep yeah we'll change it later
what do you hate that movies do is there
anything you like it's all tactical it's
so technical it's like me talking to you
but you're a tennis ball on a stick and
then I because you can't be there
because you're a monster and you're
being made up and we're not ready for
you yet it's all that it's in again it's
the deconstruction of a scene of just
two guys talking but and now it it's got
to be broken into 47 components it's
tedious movies are really tedious
I loved it that's why I like TV well
let's go man we're shooting when you're
upset at 7:00 you're the first shot is
about 7:20 yeah I don't like saying it's
a real case to sit around and wait hurry
up and wait and by the way the show is
eight o'clock on Starz yes um on Sunday
ash vs. Evil Dead when you did Fargo did
they do Fargo because I mean it said
that is one of the greatest TV series
they've done in quite some time
Fargo the movie or the TV show TV show
I'm the only actor who's been in both
were you in the movie hell yeah LG's in
the movie he didn't believe me I didn't
get when the guy's putting a leg in the
chipper yeah end of the movie the other
guys watching a shitty soap opera uh-huh
and I'm in the shitty soap opera yeah
Nate so do they film the soap opera for
the net no the Coen brothers the
producer of the Coen brothers was an old
high school buddy of mine he knew that I
had done a really bad soap opera years
before and he go it's great let's just
get the footage just get get the right -
it cost like a dollar
so that's what they did they got they it
was something we had filmed years before
and then did the people who did the TV
show did they have any idea that that
connection existed like was no no so
that was just a happy coincidence except
for the same producer John Cameron so he
he then brought me in to do Ronald
Reagan right right Tim you did use you
sat down and you should whale you did a
little rake where you again how do you
not once you once you look my kids grew
up in the Reagan era all the 80s you
couldn't get the guy off TV yeah there
you go he was the scolder in chief you
just you do Reagan I do Clinton we ask
that awesome now what's your Clinton
let's hear a little bit your clone how
he does it is what he said said it's the
content okay oh my god no I are you here
I'm a good shoulder I was like yeah I
think it's here that's actually an
excerpt from his autobiography i man
yeah well you'll appreciate I met him
once I met him in Miami how was he when
you meet him hilarious he is right oh we
it was a function for Haiti some some
relief finally I saw you ain't I've
chased women through the woods close he
blows
he yelled like that no we got the guy
who was his assistant told us me and the
star of Burn Notice he goes if you guys
get near the end of the line he'll have
more time if you get near the front of
the line he's got a blow past you like
good advice yeah got way near the end
we're 20 feet away he looks over as he
goes oh man hey so like how you did it
oh I love your show and we literally
both of us we look behind us he's not
talking about us is he a thought maybe
Dennis HOF from the body right so we
find we trying to get up there and he
says the words he goes Burn Notice is my
favorite show you play my favorite
character he's saying this to me Sam
were both over the hill warriors I'm
like 100 bills I didn't was watching
burn though yeah because he goes
Hillary's gone all week this is when she
was Secretary of State so I'm home I
watch the show all what's good show
where's the girl did he did end it with
that where's the girl that's pretty s
gonna be pretty great that's hilarious
ed he did it when when Hillary had
ammonia bill was like well I watch a lot
of TV I saw a TV that she had pneumonia
I guess just watching all his program
and I watch the shoulder it's my
favorite Kirk know he needs me that was
his cover show because he has to explain
what he does when she's gone those
ladies are lying I was watching a Burn
Notice marathon right you would say
we've been running Burn Notice like
non-stop sounds like good they're all
good I like to go basement just like you
all day yeah sir it's the one show that
you could pick it would make sense it's
like law and order right yeah yeah the
other right Otis in law or perfect boy I
was gonna ask Fargo was did they shoot
at like a TV show or a movie sort of
both yeah they have instructions they
the the show creator no Holly is he you
know they have rules because they don't
want it to be unn unn Fargo ish right
when the Coen brothers shoot their
movies they Roger Deakins is the guy
who's there cinematographer they use
certain lenses they don't use they're
not telephoto guys when you look at a
Coen Brothers movie for some reason they
like to kind of be with you in the room
they're not guys who shoot like 24 right
where it's like you're always on a 600
millimeter lens and they're finding you
down the street because they think it
looks cool mm-hmm that you can't there's
a certain rule like no lens deeper than
a certain like focal length yeah because
then it would not look like the show so
they have those kind of rules but so it
does it doesn't look like a standard but
the pace of it is TV pace we're not
really eating it it's weird they um
they're not they don't race along huh
and it was funny to hear Kirsten Dunst
go oh that the workload of television
I'm like yeah welcome to the program you
know it yeah it's a workload you got to
do it yeah yeah I was gonna ask if there
were any other if Bill Clinton was like
the peak of sort of famous I mean Bill
Clinton is beyond famous but fans
notable fans to stuff that you've done
our notice in any you know whatever
mostly bigger than right you know from
bin Laden
Alice Cooper Alice Cooper's favorite
horror films evil then that's cool
that's pretty good yeah coming from him
um I think Charlie Sheen likes to smoke
marijuana and watch evil did too
oh that's great but I want you to
Philadelphia smoke marijuana and watch
for doping [ __ ] it becomes funny oh my
god I've ever heard of that something
Jim's done is saying you know there's
all science that sounds cynical yeah oh
my god come on we're gonna watch
Philadelphia what do you think makes a
great horror film what do they make a
shitty horror film because it's weird
what works and what doesn't work yeah
you watch a horror movie just like evil
dead just even the new one was [ __ ]
Friday it just captures something and I
can't describe whether it's tension or
is just a creepy atmosphere but so many
movies miss it and then some movies just
had that this whole phase there was a
phase that's sort of ending it was
torture porn yes we put a guy's wiener
in a vise and poke it with a stick for
half an hour all right sighs you know
what
you know you can do that and filmmaking
wise that doesn't really require any
skill what takes the skills building
suspense it's really the same old stuff
of figuring out what a scene is like how
does how to mount a scene how to stage a
scene for one like where to even put the
actors and if a director doesn't know
how to do that a scene is going to play
weird and if a director is not on top of
his actress is going to seem weird like
Evil Dead unfortunately the original one
comes across as funny because you have
inexperienced actors saying crappy
dialogue that's a bad combo scary though
but it's still a scary was once once the
creature started I think what it is is
Sam Sam's approach was once the horror
started you can't stop it most of the
classic horror movies like Texas
Chainsaw Massacre right once that
Chainsaw got fired up it pretty much
didn't end until the end right and it
was it it hit a relentless point
yeah because before like before before
it's a horror movie and Texas Chainsaw
Massacre just annoying Franklin and it's
yeah
yeah yeah and then and then it goes then
it busts open yeah The Hills Have Eyes
the same sort of old classic 70s that's
you know the first rated-r movie I ever
saw was on one echo home theater WH T my
friend bill D'Angelo uh he'll be agile
and his parents at W 18 The Hills Have
Eyes is the first ray that's a scariest
movie it's a terrifying you know that
started a trend in in The Hills Have
Eyes there's a poster of Jaws that's
torn in half because it's the future and
no it's because is stupid I guess
terrible word nerdiest before me
whatever whatever happened in that movie
it's nothing like what's going on in
here right so an evil dead we took a
Hills Have Eyes poster and put it in the
basement and tore that in half so does
it actually give a message to the
audience that it's not this is nothing
compared to what you're seeing because
we're here exactly because that's a
movie but this is real yes yeah
then in this is all Wes Craven back and
forth with Sam Raimi and then in Evil
Dead we well then in then in what it was
the first Nightmare on Elm Street
I'm Erin and I'm here now sure yeah kids
watching TV late at night he's watching
the Evil Dead he's watching Evil Dead so
then when we did Evil Dead - we took
Freddie's hand Freddie's claw put that
in the work shed so they've been sort of
communicating little props back and
forth for years
does it make you scary okay it's like
hey people watching the movie have seen
jaws they've seen the Evil Dead so it's
like okay that's that's actually
relatable cuz I've seen that movie and
they see it as a movie so that's
realistic it's all subliminal torment oh
yeah you work on [ __ ] works and on many
levels you know a scary movie was the
conjuring for scary movies the first one
and the second one we're pretty yeah I
like the conjuring but you say that you
have to keep the horror going those are
ones that will kind of like back off a
little bit and then go maybe there's
just different pace in those it's more
the suspense or did you not think they
were scary um I I like stuff a pace I do
once when stuff gets going horror movies
look horror movies can get slow because
they think that slow brooding shots or
what it's all about that's actually fine
and in the original Evil Dead there are
little slow moments but there
just breathers until it starts again
like your ears clear are used to do
still try to see everything or not
really when you say see every like movie
like are yourselves like no joy horror
films you can kind of know how it I love
the process I still love the the
business but when I go to see a movie
now I watch actors look at their marks
uh it's all still too technical yes the
actors looking to hell yeah oh there's
some great ones seriously and it's a
little flick of the eyes it's all it is
once I know what they're looking forward
to going now I'm not gonna I'm not going
to out any of my brother sister actors
but it's when you're you have to run and
they're using you know telephoto lens
and then you have to hit a mark and all
you have to run you know it wasn't in
the theory of everything Bill Clinton is
chasing and you're running you get
Steve's locking head no use it as oh my
god is why the chair yeah so you get you
get to the mark and you have to stop but
you've been running right and you're
you're not supposed to look at your mark
but you have to because otherwise unless
you're a really good peripheral vision
you're going to miss your mark and if
you miss your mark go out of focus issue
that simple so you go where is it there
it is everyone is now going to look for
that I never thought to look at that
believe me I've been on sets I never
thing is watching actors save alarm
they'll be in the middle of a line and I
know that they're halfway toward [ __ ]
that thing up and they're going to
they're going to pull the way out of it
yeah Shatner's the best at it because I
watch TJ Hooker so he's good at almost
butchering one and then fixing it
normally Shatner talks at a pretty
lightning fast pace
he's William Shatner he's talking and
when sometimes the lines aren't is
obvious damn he slows down becomes more
deliberate and his approach until he
gets there then he's back spitting up a
guy's dog so some actors you'll save you
can save a line because you're like I'm
not doing this again
Wow you can see them actually doing yeah
Bruce iam bogged down and then you but
the great thing is watching them claw
their way out of it but is that all
about making them look like they're
clawing their way out of that
that's a gift and it might make it look
more natural too because that's when
you're talking you don't know exactly
what you're gonna say so you stop and
that is me there's a lot of old timey
actors they would talk like that like
radio announcers right with all the
perfect pacing because that's kind of
how they were taught then you get in the
John Cassavetes more the avant-garde
stuff and you want actors did not act
yes right I can't watch laughing she
knows you don't I mean the denier early
dinners they got into more of the
mannerisms and stutters and sniffles and
a lot actors now is my favorite okay so
say say some lines of dialogue to me um
I don't know for dinner I was thinking
maybe we can get some chicken or
something what do you think
why Bruce is looking around like what
are you looking at he's looking all
around they're gonna me and now now I'm
gonna be that same actor okay yeah I'm
gonna go to the store Oh get some
chickens okay I don't know maybe some
yeah there isn't doughnuts or whatever
I'm like where the [ __ ] what are you
looking at he's looking all over cuz I
got it is it because the actors feel
like they have to be doing some theory
makes it I think so they have to have
something else going on so they honest
cuz what is he doing is not like
impelling is a Mickey Rourke that's
almost like a Mickey Rourke it is and
you know you watch some actors the very
first time and you go oh my god they're
amazing you see in the second time you
go oh he's doing that no that's his
shtick yeah yeah and it's and it's
partly depressing I must say okay now
can that reminded me of a Mickey like
just a mysterious guy looking beyond and
got kind of finger work was great it he
was amazing
Philip Seymour Hoffman had a great way
watching out loud million in body heat
watch him he's uh when he's making his
little bomb he's got this little ticks
he's explaining it yeah is what you want
to do with your thing oh he was really
smooth Mickey Mickey work yeah now he's
lumpy yeah smooth then it's interesting
that you bring up the stuff about the
horror movies and pacing and like
because I feel like it's such a delicate
balance like there's have you seen don't
breathe I haven't but know I've said
that well [ __ ] it's the same
filmmaker from the Evil Dead remake
right I'm a big fan of a fede alvarez
this is Fetty unchained it says and it's
interesting too because I've seen it and
it is
absolutely one of these things that kind
of starts where is this going where's
this going and then it yeah he's
unrelenting I mean there there's it
starts to drift into a Gore poorni stuff
will not Gore porn but there's some
stuff that is just like so squeamish
that you're like yes Christ yeah you
have to look away but it is there's a
cup of jizz in it at one point you're
just like I don't know right reminders
of work compasses breakfast bar but it
is completely unrelenting it is that
style well that thing came I don't know
where and it was tracking lower than
what they thought they were like oh
another ho-hum release and I went yeah
it popped because word of mouth I think
it still exists yeah yeah yeah I gotta
see that move you gotta see that what's
a movie that scared the [ __ ] out of you
uh the tenant by Roman Polanski if I saw
very senior came out like 76 I saw it in
college there's no blood there's no
monster
there's no I'm trying to think of how
many only a couple people wind up losing
their actual life but at that thing
stuck with me for weeks after because it
made me think I was going crazy because
then because the the lead character was
being driven insane and that's to me
that's good horror if the word you go
what what is a it's like The Sixth Sense
yeah it's a really clever movie again if
you see that movie again you go oh but
you know the first time you go really
cuz it's messing with your head very
successful movie I never heard of the
time yeah I have attended again very
obscure but it's like wow
when filmmakers go creepy do things like
Roman like guy you talked about last II
do things like Rosemary's Baby I'll
watch that again recently and there's
still very scary moments like that you
know the fact that you know that there's
something going on next door but it's
not as scary but it's done in an adult
fashion which is why the original
Exorcist is so good yeah you have Ellen
Burstyn who's like an award-winning
actress quite watch my BAE it's not it's
not frankly with all due respect a
scream queen right being a bad actor
Friedkin is like no no we're gonna get
like actors to do this yeah
and and they treated it so they've got
these great shots just scanning her
brain hanging hanging cuz they're going
we have to find out clinically what the
problem they can't find it
the doctors can't find it just a whole
approach right and then the the if you
set up a story the correct way it can
really have a great what's a great path
the set up is it's a priest who's
doubting his faith he's the guy who gets
the kid with the Exorcist are you
kidding me
yeah that slammed up yeah who are you
gonna torment a priest full of
conviction [ __ ] the guy has he will
not get scared or anything you go after
guys like I'm not sure if I this is I'm
cut out for this little elements that
that story tell ya as an artist now
you're scared yeah you know the fact
that Bruce Willis in the air duct in the
original die hard
he was an la cop why not make him an
accountant right cystic random guy who
doesn't know [ __ ] but he's smart yeah
and he learns and he finds a gun and
he's never fired a gun in his life how
does this work right now I'm scared but
if he's the la cop that's just a
writer's cop-out yeah that's a good
point about yeah I pitched it to a
Hollywood writer I go I go why didn't
they do that when I count he goes how
would he have one I'm like that's your
problem right now
as a writer we'll figure it out right
right as an audience member I'd be
terrified if that guy is an account
you're less invested if he's a cop
because a cop has those tools already
sure yeah it doesn't get out of ego what
a lousy cop he should have been killed
he was terrible this job what's
fascinating is just by the way your beef
they remove all other options so it can
only be only me that it makes it really
also got Linda Blair they got they got
choice casting yes
again choice it was a good move it was a
good decision and look William Friedkin
is a very intense filmmaker and he's at
the height of his powers there yeah you
know filmmakers at the height of their
powers are great did you see did I know
we have to wrap up did you see part
three part two is not good the extras
part two Linda Blair is also in that but
did you see part three which was kind of
an extension of part one
milk is part two suck so bad I didn't
tell you part 3 1990 was 17 years later
and it picks up its really good me
terrible I mean my buddy watched it as a
joke and we were like two [ __ ]
teenage girls that's right not just
because we're dressed that way we really
frightened watching it was with George
see Scott plays the part that uh Lygia
Cobb played right and uh the preseason
and also uh Brad Dourif isn't it sounds
horrible horrible mark three is good but
I tell you sometimes it's good to bring
back a franchise years later for
instance ash vs. Evil Dead yeah it's all
these stars back from the dead
Sundays at 8:00 p.m. you can go to Bruce
- Campbell dot-com or at groovy Bruce
always good talking to you man thanks
for having me one of my favorite guests
every what should you say something is
Reagan well there you go again and well
they are barbarians we start bombing in
five minutes no Nancy there we go
I had my salad tossed by Cicely Tyson